listening to a film
and Terry warden
David how did you get Public Enemy
rapper Chuck D involved with this film
since 1988 I've been the biggest
publican to be fan that I know my first
I heard their legendary it takes a
nation of millions to hold us back album
I was hooked and I followed them you
know I've just followed them forever and
in the late 90s as email and web sites
were starting to come into into being
and things like that it is becoming more
accessible the online world Chuck made
himself available and put out his email
address and and so I started to email
them you know he he put commentary up in
his website asked for replies and
thoughts and I would do that and then he
started writing me back and it was like
wow this is very weird as well I do
music production and things like that
and so I would send him some music and
he he had an online radio show and he
play some music and and you know we we
developed a relationship through there
and then I told him look I do video too
I'd like to do a video for you guys
after that it just kind of kept
ballooning like that and Chuck said why
don't you be the music video guy for my
label and so I started doing all the
videos for the slam jams label for
Chuck's lamp James label and eventually
that led to me doing the videos for
Public Enemy when it came around to do
in the film i said to him i originally I
was going to approach him for money and
I said I said Chuck hey um I got a
script and we're gonna shoot this film
you know and I was about to say you know
I need I need a little bit of money can
you help out and before I got that far
he cut me off he said you gotta roll for
me